Nó này mừng năm tặng năm 2018, trên cú lộ một đạn qua sợ phu khối tình vĩnh lắm,
sẽ ra vụ tên hạnh ra thông phíanh bà người thương vòng.
Thông tin bà đầu, khoảng hai dởi bộ miếp phu khủng này, anh tên nở tê,
bà miệ sảo tuổi ở sã Trung thành, vĩnh lòng, đưa khiến sẽ trở giác só miếp từ a
một chiến 122 một lưu thông rướng cình thơ, vĩnh lòng, khi đến địa phẩn sã phu khối thị dừng
bây lệ phẩn đi lấy giác. Lúc này, ô tô còn sống miếp từ a 3 1 xo anh lơ tê hát,
2 tư tuổi ở phu nglong châu, bĩnh lòng, đưa khiến chở thông an sã thê,
2 tụi, ở phung sĩnh sã, anh dạng, bà an nở phía đe, 2 tụi, ở sã của lâu dê vô,
anh dạng, lưu thông cùng chiều bất ngờ và trảm vào phần đùi xe chở giác.
Hậu qua, anh hát đi thương nạc, đưa đưa đi cấp đứa tệ bình Việt đã qua tình vĩnh lòng.
Anh tê và anh đe thương vong tại chốt, hịt bụt tên nạn đạng đực ke quan cây rất đưa trà công an tình vĩnh lòng tiếp tục đưa trà, làm só.